dans ce monde d'hommes il y a une
tradition à laquelle il est interdit de
déroger
la poignée de main rituel du soir parce
que c'est dit bonjour à tous nos
collègues c'est pas parce qu'on est
nombreux qu'eux a pas à rougir au
programme de la nuit une urgence sur la
ligne 2 une voix usée doit être changé
ce soir tu as un convoi avec le milieu
de la ligne 2 il est prévu de faire son
emplacement
vincent n'a pas une seconde à perdre
comme chaque nuit le temps est compté il
n'a que trois heures pour remplir sa
mission
la première difficulté c'est d'acheminer
sous terre les tonnes de matériel
nécessaire au changement de la ram
pour gagner du temps ils utilisent ce
robot spécialement conçu pour descendre
les escaliers du métro
vincent et son équipe n'ont plus qu'à
attendre le passage du dernier train
l'allée qui vont se vider on va vraiment
être tout seul il y aura il y aura pu en
bouillie dans la station les
travailleurs voilà en quelque sorte oui
on est aussi sombre que le tunnel
quelques minutes après la fermeture de
la station la pièce à changer arrive un
aiguillage de 4 tonnes pour 18 mètres de
long donc là voilà il est deux heures du
matin on vient d'avoir le coup de feu
donc c'est bon de commencer à travailler
on a trois heures avant que de remettre
le courant sur les voies c'est une
course contre la montre pas là le timing
est serré et ça commence mal
vraisemblablement tout le monde n'est
pas encore très bien réveillé
l'aiguillage a été chargé dans le
mauvais sens bon balayer ça s'annonce
plus dure que prévu bien envers le demi
aiguillages et à l'envers ça commence
pas très très ce qui aurait dû être fait
en une heure de temps ça va sûrement
prendre des ordres
l'heure tourne mais pas question de se
précipiter la moindre erreur de
manipulation de cette pièce de quatre
tonnes pourrait blesser l'un de ses
hommes
[Musique]
certains tapent sa vie à tant besoin
la manipulation doit être ses douces
ceux ci se met à balancer ou raï de ce
poids là en fait les crasses nous c'est
son choix
le but c'est pas qu'ils aient les
actions de pareilles
tout le monde rentre chez soi tant en
bonne santé non les gars mettez des
cales
le plus dur commence il faut maintenant
remettre la pièce dans le bon sens
à la force du poignet après deux heures
d'efforts
l'aiguillage est enfin prêt il faut
maintenant le fixer au rail
bon les gars là pour les soutenir
la saison
[Musique]
il est presque cinq heures du matin
malgré les imprévus la mission est
accomplie
très bien donc là toute la pièce est
assemblée au niveau de l'horaire on est
parfait la pièce est prêtre est
applicable à faire le renouvellement les
hommes de vincent qui tu les vois juste
avant l'arrivée du premier métro
[Musique]